We want to solve a real problem.
It's better if we could
address a real pain point and
not just nice to have feature.
If you can create a real value for your
users, they will be happy to pay for it.
>> Harnessing habits
leads to more revenue.
It drives a higher customer
lifetime value, and
it gives us greater
flexibility to increase prices.
If you are able to
create a customer habit,
it will super charge
your monetization plan.
>> However, it's a challenge.
First, make sure users form a habit,
using your app at least once or
twice a day is a good start.
Second, identify the four
aspects of your product.
Triggers, actions,
rewards and investments.
In the following videos,
we will see how to identify them.